howard beck bleacher report columnist
joining us on the program was kevin
durant stay in golden state good for the
NBA oh boy
i tend to not look at these things as
what's good or bad for the NBA den but
just kind of what is and then we just
see where where the consequences of it
are but i mean now that it's over
look there's this there's this love/hate
thing we do with dynasties with super
teams from we love them or love to hate
them you resent them and i know in this
case it because people didn't feel like
it was organically built or because
durant joined it a ready-made
championship team that that somehow made
it even worse than the average i don't
care about any of that but i do think
that you know the ratings show that
there was incredible interest in the
playoffs in the finals the last few
years i think local ratings were down in
the last few years on a lot of the
regional sports networks which it's hard
to define what that means it may mean
that there's a lack of hope and intrigue
in certain markets because of the fact
that it felt like the championship was
preordained it's hard to know how to
analyze that i do think that this five
year warriors run in total with and
without durant the whole thing it was
good for the NBA and that people were
really really interested in the Warriors
and the Warriors played an incredible
brand of basketball with some of the
greatest players in the sports history
and people wanted to watch that so now i
think on balance it was probably good i
also think that the crash-and-burn now
of the Warriors or at least the
temporary pause means there's going to
be a lot more intrigue about next season
and who can win the title even though
their Warriors Hart the defending
champions it's just going to feel a lot
more wide open and I have to think
that's a good thing if you could say to
Durant prior to making that decision
Golden State this is what's going to
happen you're gonna win a couple of
titles and you're gonna blow out your
Achilles and then you're going to leave
what do you sign up for that ooh
interesting
I think most guys would tell you at the
outset hell yes I think you know and we
see it all the time right we see guys
sacrifice their bodies in the sport not
all of them do we've seen you know Kobe
Bryant plays for all kinds of like
ridiculous stuff you know we all know
you know been football running a lot
chopping off his pinky or part of it
I mean athletes will go to extreme
lengths at times to guarantee themselves
the chance to win much less the
guarantee to win so if you're telling
him this is the bargain you're paying in
advance your deal with the devil you're
going to spend three years there win two
titles two Finals MVPs but you're going
to leave with a pretty lousy injury at
age almost 31 I think he might take it
we're talking to Howard back bleacher
report NBA reporter columnist in SAR you
an insider how does that guy get are you
an outsider an insider Howard I kind of
think of myself as more of the outsider
I'm not sure I'm comfortable with you
being an insider there's a lot of
pressure
all right so what are you hearing about
Kawhi Leonard and and what what is this
coming down to that he needs time to
make his decision it's a great question
quick observation here Kawhi Leonard who
we've thought of as the most no drama no
nonsense superstar all this stuff he's
the one who's actually dragging things
out like Kevin Durant Kyrie Irving made
their decision right off the bat Jimmy
Butler is already in place everybody
else is already in place it's Kawhi
Leonard's the guy who never wants
anybody to look at him pay attention
mister no drama
mister low maintenance he's the guy
who's dragging us at this now got us all
hostage how about that yeah I I don't
you know listen it's it's hard for us to
know what's going through his head you
know even on smaller things much less
something his weight he is where he's
going to spend the rest of his career
potentially so I don't know I suspect
you know look first of all this is his
first free agency the this is this is a
David I think difficult decision for him
if things had gone badly in one year in
Toronto it's easy to leave but things
went spectacularly on every level not
just the championship but just the
connection I think he had with that
organization with his teammates with the
entire country of Canada and I think
part walking away from that would be
difficult I think that both LA teams
present some really attractive
possibilities I think that he initially
as we know from a year ago wanted to go
home to Southern California and that
that pole is still there and the Lakers
you know are do you really want to go be
the third wheel to LeBron
James and Anthony Davis that I mean
maybe maybe they feel like they could
just then go dominate the league for the
next five years I don't know I mean
these are three very different options
and trade-offs and there's the
possibility of staying and going short
on a contract you know anybody who's
trying to guess what's in Kauai said is
a fool it just feels like the media is
hopeful he goes to the Lakers you know
if he stays in Toronto then it's like
now Kay stayed in Toronto and you know
you battered the Clippers like I I think
it's more interesting if he went to the
Clippers than the Lakers we won't change
we'd like change how many times do we
get to a trade deadline and we're gonna
all guy this guy could be traded this
guy could be trade then you wake up the
next day and go who got traded you know
it's some sixth man who got traded this
is a big deal because this impacts
LeBrons legacy I know we love using that
word legacy but it impacts his legacy
and Kauai --zz legacy as well fee wins a
third title with a third different team
you know maybe tax on a couple more you
know he moves up that list of great
players of all time Anthony Davis with
what it does for him the Lakers
organization I don't know that's a it's
a big I don't know if it's a seismic
shift in the history of the game I think
I think Sunday is gonna be was one of
those days that we're gonna look back
and say that was a pretty big day in NBA
history but you know Kauai if he ends up
with the Clippers is more interesting
than him going to the Lakers I agree
him going to the Lakers I think
everybody on the one hand you're right I
mean we're all addicted to transactions
and to change is more interesting than
than just static
you know inertia I think him going to
the Lakers though will cause a lot of
people to roll their eyes and say okay
here we go again okay like Kawhi Leonard
who at this very moment might be the
best player in the world is going to go
join up with two of the other top five
players in the world and people you know
here we go another super team another
LeBron let's super team any of those
Laker fans who criticize the Golden
State Warriors for adding Kevin Durant
we're gonna have to go you know on
second thought yeah I mean it's always
great with it's your team
you know although listen I read a lot of
credit too
I should acknowledge this and that there
are a lot of Warriors fans who never
really warm to Kevin Durant we're always
kind of resentful of him being there and
stealing some of Steph Curry spotlight
because there a lot of Warriors fans who
are Steph Curry
you know stands more than anything and
they don't want to that never really
wanted Kevin Durant to take any of his
spotlight and they kind of think and we
kind of want it without him anyway
they're wrong but you know so I think
that for Laker fans will be really
interesting to Dan because they haven't
really embraced LeBron through year one
like it really kind of IIIi think
distant relationship right now that
LeBron and LA have with each other yeah
and in part it's because the way the
season went in part because he got there
as a guy who was already a decorated
champion in multiple time MVP and he
didn't do it on on their watch and so
they're not sure what to make of him and
now ad is another hired gun and then
Kawhi is gonna come in as a hired gun
and I know that's been the laker way in
in in the past but it's usually been a
combination of homegrown and hired guns
so it's a it's a strange dynamic in
terms of how they'll embrace that team
but listen Google Lakers
you know and they're fans of
Championships more than anything and
having Kawhi there would almost
guarantee it I'm not sure it's good for
the we're gonna go back to the web yeah
for the league what's good for the game
Hawaiian joining the Clippers would be
excellent having a true LA versus LA
rivalry would be great
the fact that the nets are now cast in a
whole new light because Kyrie Irving and
Katie chose them and so the two teams
and that are you know the the stepchild
in their markets the Clippers and nets
both having done a lot of great work to
last years to earn that and if they both
end come out of this with all-stars is
also good for the health of league in
that it just shows that hey look if you
put things together the right way and
you build a foundation and you're and
you're smart the top talent will want to
come to you I'll leave you with this
with the Knicks game plan I know it's
easy to pick on them but I was trying to
defend you know the Knicks that maybe
they were just being prudent with Kevin
Durant but if Kevin Durant was not going
to the Knicks if Kyrie wanted to go to
the Nets and he wanted to play with
Kyrie and
DeAndre Jordan that I don't understand
why we're ripping the Knicks because
they didn't want to give Kevin Durant a
a five year they didn't want to give him
the max deal but if he wasn't going
there then it didn't they could give him
you know fifty years it didn't matter
they he was not going there in the first
place or am I missing something here
because it doesn't feel like he was ever
considering the Knicks or truly
considering the Knicks I reported this
yesterday and the quote I got from
somebody who is very knowledgeable in a
situation said there was quote zero
chance that the contract from the Knicks
contract offer from the ex had anything
to do with Kevin Durant not going
there's zero
zero chance he chose the Nets over the
Knicks in part because Kyrie was going
to go to the Nets and they want to play
together and in part because he and
Kyrie both had concluded over the course
of the season that the nets were in much
better shape than the Knicks were and
that they were the better place to land
and so it didn't matter whether the
Knicks were offering one year two year
four years a hundred years max not Matt
it didn't matter that he wasn't going to
go there so the Knicks are off the hook
in that regard but I will say this
putting that out there making sure that
people knew we weren't going to go to
the to the wall on it is absolutely
self-serving because you're trying to
get yourself off the hook in the sense
that you're trying to show that we were
being prudent we were being thought what
we were trying not to to do something
dumb and that's why we lost him like no
that's not why you didn't get him and by
the way everybody else in the league
would have taken the risk and giving him
the four year max again we see Achilles
yeah um so I that does not get them off
the hook and then they're still just the
fact of they did in the wake of not
getting the targets that they wanted and
by the way that's the other thing
they're they're it's disingenuous for
the next tip to try to pretend that they
weren't all out for Katie Kyrie and by
the way DeAndre Jordan as the third
piece who the Nets also got it's
disingenuous to say they weren't
targeting that package the entire season
that's exactly what they wanted they
didn't get it just you know acknowledged
that you missed and move on and you know
the guys that they signed I'm not sure
where where it gets them I'm not sure
how this advances their cause it makes
them slightly better next year but I
don't I don't know what the Knicks plan
is right now no I
I know for a fact from a source
and and the quote that I got from
somebody with the Knicks was as long as
we don't screw this up we're gonna get
Kevin Durant that was the quote that I
was I was given that quote laid in the
sea and during the playoffs as long as
we don't screw it up we're gonna get
Kevin Durant but imagine if they had
gotten Scion Williamson yeah how would
that change anybody's mind of wanting to
play for the Knicks I think it would
have given them more pause for sure now
listen I'm the first to say and I always
will say this and this includes Diane
Williamson it is extremely rare for a
rookie to come in and be ready to win on
day one and Zion Williamson certainly
has some work to do in terms of
developing his game at the NBA level he
is an incredible athletic just dynamo
and he's going to have a very good NBA
career there's not universal you know
just agreement that he's going to be a
superstar and so on day one if you're
Kyrie and KD and you need a team that
can win immediately because you know
Vince certainly in Katie's case you're
older then I don't know if that would
have done enough or not because the rest
of that next roster is still pretty act
but it wouldn't have been his team it
would have been Zions team not Katie's
and Katie wants his own team Katie Katie
wouldn't have thought of it as ions team
I don't think maybe I also but Dan I
also think this if they'd gotten the
draft rights design if they'd won the
lottery I think there would have been a
strong temptation and probably even a
very good case to be made that they
should have that they should then trade
that pick to get the veterans that they
need to create the team that Katie and
Kyrie could win with immediately so the
universe how about this if you're the
Knicks and you can only have one you're
gonna have Zion or KD Zion or post
Achilles Katie yeah I'm gonna take I'm
going to take Zion only because when
Katie comes back he's going to be 32
he's turning 32 in September of 2020 and
we don't expect to see him playing into
October 2020 and if nothing else it's
the fact that I don't feel like I'm
gonna get a long enough run with him and
with Zion even though like I'm still in
kind of like the let's wait and see camp
I'm not proclaiming
Xion MVP and a ten-time all-star yet I
don't know what he's going to be I do
know that getting a guy on day one
especially as exciting a player as he is
and having him for potentially his whole
career letting your team grow with him
your fans grow with him the emotional
investment and the payoff that that
brings is more satisfying and healthier
for the franchise because it gives you
an identity that endures for longer and
katie is you know on the you know the
back end of his career he's the senior
NBA rider for bleacher report Howard
great to check in with you thank you as
always thank you Dan appreciate it for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]